I was planning on sending it to the Cheekswap today Monday but Saturday was an Ivy was an Ivy started coming out and instead today I'm at bed stat getting a steroids shot and a prescription for more person talking to boys and Ivy.
I have it really bad assume I should wait to send the Cheekswap and how long.
So this so given the rest of this question this person is talking about poison I poison I've started coming out meeting maybe a rash from poison I've started coming out of the skin.
So how long should I wait before I do a cheek swan.
Well, you the poison ivy rashes get effects of the cheek swan for cancer so you can still do some of the cheeks for the cancer.
Also, what's your recommended recommendation for treating poison ivy.
OTC over the color. I really want to avoid the shot but the poison ivy is too bad this time don't PSA don't pet strange dogs you don't know what they've been.
So there's a lot of treatment things for poison ivy that you could search on the internet.
I remember when we lived in the woods we had lots of poison ivy and I got to the point where I was basically just immune to it I could literally pick it out of my garden.
I didn't even break out so we just got to that point. We have poison ivy where our office is now because our office is a whole so about 12 acres and I get exposed to poison ivy every year again a little bit of a rash as long as I tried out through to it.
I don't get it too bad of an issue but there's some people that end up developing it.
IGG IGG antibodies to poison ivy and then they break out really bad and they get really blistered and such.
But it is the I think it's both your siral acid oil that is really the contaminated to poison ivy so the.
You have to get the oil off your mind so using you can't just wash the skin with water when you're exposed to poison ivy because it won't because oil repels water so you have to use some sort of oil.
So a leader to get it off your body so many people recommend some of the leaders that would be used some of the solvents that would be used as hand leaders for like mechanics.
I can't remember the name of them right now but I used to have them.
I think it was group or something like that that was in a jar I had in my garage in my work bench so that when I got really oily skin from working with my chains are something I would grab so that I can clean off my hands using something like that that's oil.
Solvable that will help pull that out off the skin is the best thing once you already get the reaction of poison ivy there are anti inflammatory things you could do for the nutritional standpoint but still it's hard to get to the skin obviously most people are using the steroid creams and stuff for poison ivy and that gets to be difficult.
I had a patient years ago that had a company that sold poison ivy treatment stuff but I can't remember the name of that company actually gave me some of the product to try.
I believe I still haven't somewhere I've never had to use it my kids have never had to use it we don't have poison ivy in our house you really have 20 acres of our house we just don't have poison ivy there so we haven't had to use it so.
I just they probably sell their stuff on Amazon I would look at Amazon for a poison ivy treatment and there's probably some good products out there this guy used to score that did they they started their company because them or one of their kids or something had a form of a formal reaction so they did the research and put the products together I would try something.
But could the steroids interfere the question is really could the steroids interfere with the sheikh's law no if I know that you're on steroids i'll take that into consideration but if you're if you're.
Maybe you should wait at least a week and tell your mom the steroids are said it in just to be safe and if you're at a crisis mode we can work around it but you're not at a crisis mode so let's wait till you're off the steroids give it a good three or four days off the steroids and then you're the sheikh's law.